he's doing terrific Roberts good yeah
he's working out eating good Rob
Kardashian
coming back into the spotlight and a
source tells et that Rob is doing better
than ever
he's on a good path right now not only
has the Kardashian sisters baby brother
made a social-media comeback a source
tells et Rob is much happier and has
been around his family more after years
of being a homebody Rob and his family
are excited for this new journey Rob is
on I know Rob is doing great he really
is Rob grabbed everyone's attention last
week when he shared these photos from
his sister Khloe's birthday party while
he's rarely posted new photos of himself
to social media in recent years Rob
shared these photos where he does indeed
look happy while surrounded by his
family he's doing great you know he
definitely is more low-key than all of
us and we love that and respect that Kim
even told ET back in November that Rob
was already on a positive path we love
having him around yeah he's doing really
good e t--'s source also said Rob is in
the best place he hasn't been doing this
well in years he's been taking his
workouts and eating well serious and has
seen significant results last summer
Khloe raved 2et about Rob's workout
routine you know he's been working out a
couple you know sukoon he goes to Kim's
who's worked out for like in the past
five days or so and he's kicking ass and
I just want Rob to do what's best for
him and what makes him happy and if that
makes him happy then we will all support
him
[Music]
you